- EVERYONE KNOWS OUR TARGET
AUDIENCE...
IS 18 TO 34-YEAR-OLD MALES.
BUT HOW DO WE
HIT THAT TARGET?
- HOW?
BY RELYING ON MARKET TESTING?
NO.
- [scoffs]
- BY TRUSTING OUR GUT?
NO.
WE NEED MORE.
LARS.
AND SO
FOR THE PAST SIX MONTHS,
WE HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING
A PROTOTYPE
THAT COMBINES ALL
OF OUR TARGET VIEWERS
INTO ONE COMPOSITE VIEWER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THE FUTURE OF TELEVISION.
[thudding]
A FULLY FUNCTIONAL
18 TO 34-YEAR-OLD MALE.
- PIZZA.
- LET'S GIVE THEM A LITTLE
DEMONSTRATION
OF HOW HE WORKS.
[TV turns on]
[upbeat music]
- [robot beeps]
[all applaud]
- HE LOVES IT.
[seductive music]
[moaning]
[robot beeps]
HE LIKES IT.
THAT'S A HIT.
- UH, GEORGE, IF I MAY?
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON A LITTLE
SHOW MYSELF
AND I GAVE IT TO LARS AND,
WELL, I'M CURIOUS TO SEE
WHAT THE DEMO MONSTER
THINKS ABOUT IT.
I THINK HE'S GONNA LOVE IT.
- OH.
IT'LL BE A TRUE TEST.
- FELL PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT IT, GEORGE.
- I'M LIZ.
[cameras snapping]
I'M AN AMAZING PERSON
WITH AN AMAZING LIFE.
- AND I'M LIZ.
I'M--
[gunfire]
[robot buzzes angrily]
- YOU KNOW WHAT, LET ME ACTUALLY
GIVE HIM A DIFFERENT SKETCH.
[gun reloads]
OH, GOD, NO!
[gunfire]
- [guttural moaning]
[wet noises]
- YOU THINK HE'S
BADLY HURT, LARS?
- [flatulence]
- [dings]